I swear to God on my life I'm telling
you I'm gonna say something wired this
is where it gets weird pretty weird
already I will never talk to you again
if there's not a video there's plenty of
time get [ __ ] done I'm gonna make Monday
morning my [ __ ] what is this oh it's
it's a just a ring my sister made
how'd you sell them they're really cool
I yeah I feel like I don't really cool
let me take it off there there
well it's wet now it's not well you you
know they're adjustable they're like
these Southwest weird yeah she's moving
it she's moving all right yes are they
there you're like 11 bucks now they
gotta be 22 empty text or something like
that
22 I don't want to quote it but they're
cheaper than 22 bucks her shy doing she
doesn't matter like it's good I'm having
a baby enlarge my man congratulations
give me a last minute advice yes
last-ditch effort advice yes kill to me
you're gonna be so [ __ ] scared the
first hundred days and then the rest is
gonna be the greatest thing that ever
happened to you I believe that it's true
I'm already horrified no I believe that
when I do if you think you're horrified
now wait till there's an actual thing
when you're like actually looking at it
you're like holy [ __ ] it's crazy dude I
don't let her do anything she wants to
kill me she your wife
yeah I'm a paranoid son of a [ __ ] I
mean I think she wanted to kill you
before yeah all right tell me everything
your music started oh you always were
Thai you so like here decides you wanna
make music
that I period to right but honestly what
you did on vine is what you did to your
a great communicator and you're a really
creative dude I appreciate that I mean
like this is a foregone conclusion for
me at some level there's it's you've
already achieved more attention than
you've got to put things in perspective
what you did in those early days of mine
if you actually quantify all the people
that ever lived that were ever able to
amass attention you would be humbled by
what your all-time rank is that's a
great yeah it's really crazy what that
movie is so I'll tell you I'll tell you
what to just yeah and I'll tell you yes
and I'll tell you what's interesting
just like you walked in here said whoa
the world yeah I agree
I always talk about that I'm frustrated
but that's what wakes me up and that's
me test rates me is that they don't know
my potential I love that my breasts rate
no no that's good that's not frustration
I do too much bitterness I'm not bitter
but I'm angry bitterness in a sense that
like it's a it's a chip on the shoulder
thing yes but you guys won now so it's
all over you can't yes actually want
something yes so so what's happening
tell me I mean you had that one moment
several years ago where at the height of
the buying stuff you let put out a song
of course that did well right I feel
like a Jewish American rapper my style
okay thanks man we're gonna use it in
this episode thanks man you guys I know
what's going on I know well what are you
why don't you tell more curious about
you but well good like tell me what you
said I don't really get a lot of time
there sit down dude yeah from that you
were like and the guy came in hey oh
that little bit this is actually very
wild were you I'm filming a hologram I'm
actually giving keynotes in hologram
form
ah are you [ __ ] Tupac yes this is
amazing so that's that but what's going
on in general is probably what what do
you think they Rock what am i give real
[ __ ] serious about me like it's my
brand that call in the car and I feel
that my dad used to tell me that you
said something you probably don't even
[ __ ] remember because you're such a
transmitter yep your transceiver but
you're damn good you said like I gotta
get them to Know Who I am and I have to
be it's almost like you're like you're
acknowledging the game well you know
twenty they have to know who I am before
we can on a mainstream line that's
something like well my big thing is it's
the same ways I see you the night of the
first askgaryvee book tour in Oklahoma
City
March Blaster : mark
Oklahoma City yeah oh yeah and if we're
family
really
interesting here's what I know why shoot
so bad you what's up are gonna have a
very similar career to me in different
versions which is my YouTube and Twitter
success was your vine success sure
people don't get it look if you're good
enough sure you keep coming but you
don't die sure you're a cockroach well
it's also because I was yeah making a
mistake
I said it to people what I have to I'm
confrontational son of a [ __ ] though
yeah I guess what I like about you I've
told people that my wife today was like
just be nice and be calm and be yourself
and I was like okay honey yeah but I'm
also a dick I am like I'm a dick I love
my work and you do too you love your
work you believe in it yep if you didn't
miss so tell me what's going on shaking
it here because you decide to get
serious about music I feel like New York
what happened we bought I remember when
you were going through a transition here
at this place in volume and then we were
talking and you were like I'm gonna go
kind of this route and live what
happened because I want to do a million
things right at Cannes I want to just
focus on something very very hard and
own it and own it so that anybody else
who tries to do it will not be able to
do it and which is what is be a musician
but people are musicians be nicholas
megalis the musician understood now
that's great no one can make courses
like I can and no one has the vision I
have people at the latest song that he
sent me can you play in the background
Vanessa really it's cool it's a cool
track but we're trying to make music for
you know for me but for people you have
it for know if you don't have it it's I
think that everything is coming together
the Wi-Fi it's making sense
finally and I'm out here trying to build
a team I'm trying I need a team man
but Timmy do what I want I want my team
my killers what does that mean I want
good management management I'm if
there's you know I'm doing this all
myself I'm doing this myself in Pasadena
you know that's what I'm doing I mean I
do this all myself on the internet and
where are you social network wise right
now like where do you sit [ __ ] love
Instagram I'm an artist it's visual yeah
but for me it makes sense
how many followers we have on that mute
160 great you are
I'm telling you a minute you get it I
don't have to go anywhere else for you
yeah no I get it too I go to you yeah
see the full twin yeah but you boom boom
boom boom boom four times a day you
entertain me for three or four times a
[ __ ] day
excuse my language for God's sake but
you you told me that you sat me down in
a room when I first met you and I had
known you for about five minutes then
you said you're gonna have a million
followers this time next year I laughed
I remember and you said no you're going
to you were like what the [ __ ] doesn't
this kid get you're like everybody's
going to I know you didn't quite mean
that but like no what do you mean I
didn't mean it anyone who say when we
were in 315 and I was just building out
that office I knew that I told all of
you [ __ ] what you were gonna do what
nice because of our abilities but
because that's the way the [ __ ] world
is going no I knew that vine was going
to get much much bigger I knew that you
guys sat at the top of it and that you
were gonna all exponentially get bigger
plus i that time knew that we would be
doing brandy like that I was gonna be
help you you know okay I definitely I do
it I have that I have everybody
everybody who works at Boehner everybody
who is involved yes what it's the right
thing to do you know that those dudes
are gonna hustle and that he's gonna
hustle you know it's the most important
thing when you're building something
I've seen dude there's a vibe in Vayner
that's like it's like
everybody's having a good time and it's
all productive and it's this creative
energy but make no [ __ ] mistake like
you guys are hauling ass 100% it had
yeah that was inspiring to see that so
what's going on with um so the one thing
that didn't happen that I wish did was
you didn't siphon enough of the vine
audience to other places right you
didn't make the conservative effort for
a month to really pull them into
different channels right I guess III
been picking a lot of it was super super
you know and I I get it I'm learning I'm
telling you man I'm at a different place
than I was three years ago like I'm in a
different place of course you are but
I'm also it's not just that we're having
a baby like you're not you and I don't
um can't wait gonna be gorgeous I mean
me and with your hair yeah the mo joke
my wife is Lebanese yeah your salver
you're gonna have a house in a different
place and I wanted to make I wanted
listen I I didn't understand the power
at that moment because it had never
happened now of course [ __ ] quickly
so fast dude it was like you went from
babysitter to like super star almost
overnight overnight so I'm telling you I
sat there and refreshed five hundred
thousand more people six hundred
thousand more people seven hundred
thousand more people when that's
happening you're calling everybody
desperately like we gotta get a music
video done we gotta get on tour we gotta
do this distance isn't this I'm one man
there's a lot of stubbornness to me Gary
like yeah I got it I'm not all about
just getting the quickest [ __ ] out
that's I know that and I'm also I know
that also not not um I'm in the business
of nicholas megalis i always have been
yeah but I don't want to make I don't
want to make decisions that will ever D
be a deviate or or take and take away
from what I'm trying to do I don't want
I didn't come out to LA to be in
somebody's band or be on a sitcom like
it's got to be Nicholas
well that makes sense I don't think
you've ever I don't think you've ever
shown any patterns that are contrary to
that you've always been a stubborn brain
bro no but I don't think it's stubborn
no I think you know I don't I don't play
ball probably as much as I show but I
want to and that's that's kind of my
goal man you're inspiring in that way
you talk about being able to to get what
you want by putting in the work yourself
and that's always I think the other
thing is is that for me is an
interesting thing because I think the
difference is I'm businessman comma I
have motivational tendencies I'm
artistic in some ways you're an artist
shakaama sure and you're developing the
business savviness along the way sure
that's that is a very big factor I'm an
artist that had to figure out how to
have money when you had when you started
getting money back in the bank money
yeah you don't understand what did you
do with it we just shot a music video in
the desert on our own dime on our own
money you know we're doing everything
ourselves so once the last one for last
time what's when's the last time you did
a brand deal back in a day like how long
is it basil a so oh you're doing stuff
oh yeah I do worry a bit of consulting
for companies to it I like I like going
that's crowned up yep I like I like
conceptual work yeah I like I like art
directing have you run into any of the
old crew here yeah you're in there yeah
just a - I know that I know that but I
mean serendipitously I mean it's still a
it's still a special time it is yeah I
mean I will never forget that meeting of
the old office I won't either
so thank you for that honestly yeah
those funds the least I can do is so
what can what can I help you you think
I'm being dead serious
what can we help each other with okay I
mean look and everybody be my crew knows
this I'm funny I don't I don't want or
need anything from anybody to be very
frank I even prefer I even prefer it
that way I feel that I'm thank you
I'm sure mo that's my mo I know that
that's my mo I'm able to get what I'm
you're also self-sustaining correct
you're so sufficient correct
so even
so every correct so that's that's just
true so that's why I'm interested in
knowing when I can help with this is
mine so you know I'm I'm up for whatever
like if you like do you like is
management like something like I can
maybe help you with I don't know the
mystery that well but your big dream at
this point and really kind of always is
to be a musician is to make music but
also make it and in a way that is do
whatever of lots of people that live in
2017 which a lot of bands don't [ __ ]
get it
they make bands think that it's all
about hardcore touring and selling merch
and it is well that's where the
economics are that's where they're gonna
make their money yeah once they've
developed a catalog I've been working
for ten years to make a catalog of music
that I now feel at this point Gary after
this much time it's finally decent so
now I have my guns but I have my army of
my songs and my music and I'm a package
it and get it out to people and way
they'll understand
I think that's visual it's entirely
visual look what we did with look at
dude I tried grammar one internationally
for two songs but already like because
of what Devine days find up on vine we
did dummy money was number one in five
countries and if I was such a baby let
me have sweet shirt at number one at hip
hop
I'll let do it again well the problem is
you don't have that distribution of
awareness I have like 11 if I had the
view you had the view it was called your
vine account sure yeah you so to me
let's take a step back sure instead of
what you're doing right now
one man's point of view in trying to win
in a way that I think you have less
control sure and the majority of people
are trying to go through that path sure
my question is do you believe that you
can replicate your social reach the way
you that mean it's very hard cuz you are
the right guy at the right time sure but
you know I went through that let me know
this that's right so let me tell you a
story in the second one let me tell you
a story that's gonna
but what's so funny what what's so funny
though is that was the biggest control
you have you know that right at the
moment you were lying on Regan and
Interscope and the way the game is
played you're way less in control than
you were on vine you know that right
course of course yes so my intuition is
is a little bit different let me explain
I and these guys will tell you and you
know probably know this at this point I
was the guy in tech one of the guys in
two thousand six seven eight Twitter
right oh yeah but then I wasn't as much
even when I met you guys I wasn't really
focusing on my brand I was building a
business right yes I guess what I'm
saying to you is I wasn't there you know
I wasn't I wasn't focused on a million
on Twitter but they were they were out
uh-huh and passive and dying off yeah
but now not that I have the biggest
numbers but I'm definitely again at a
very good place I think I'm fearful vibe
wise that I think you can replicate it
multiple times okay and I think you
succumb in your own mind to that was
this great moment of time [ __ ] I could
have maximized it even more it's gone I
wish I had it and I think you because of
who you are if you don't force yourself
to doing it the way you've decided in
your head it has to go now
and went back a little bit to the DNA
that got you there in the first place
yes I think you could go organically
from 150,000 to a million followers on
Instagram because you're good enough
creatively hey do you understand
of course I do man I mean
what was very what was very hard for me
and this was hard for me the most
confident sure the most confident was oh
[ __ ]
will I ever be one of the guys on one of
the next platforms even the vine thing
was interesting to me force because I
wanted to be able to find a way that was
valuable to both parties to incorporate
even I would you know cuz I felt so
close to you I'd pin you once so I'll be
like hey let's do a collaboration yes
but I could never get myself there in
the real way in my own mind because I
had decided that maybe that had passed
that's the punchline my man my man
that's the punchline
that's instead of deciding that that era
has left I think that you should at
least debate this meeting go sit home
and say Nicholas look at my face when
I'm about to tell you you can be the
number one follow person on musically
it's you so damn young dude oh really
and vine didn't my man no it didn't to
begin with no I did dude you're talking
I was there too it's not I was I wasn't
followed like you were but I was paying
very close attention maybe more
attention let me help you make more more
more attention well true I mean it's
straight over time I know here's a punch
like in six month you decided to create
for musically decided to create for
Instagram create for the platform not
create the romantic thing you've decided
that you are you can replicate it if you
choose that's the right move the only
thing I'm doing for you because I love
you is giving you the permission to
understand that truth I get it what's
plan B plan B is to be like everybody
else in this town and [ __ ] be at the
mercy of organizations that don't give a
[ __ ] about you that's Plan B
[ __ ] great what
a horrifying reality who you've painted
it for me
that's plan B I got to tell you
something yes sir my dad's first
generation Greek huh and I think that's
why I love you because of this is this
is like my father talking except you're
way younger than my dad
don't tell me I was hoping those over no
I'm telling you I'm telling you brother
you can do it eval ''tis
you can do it again yes I know I can I
know I can but you've decided you don't
want it that way and I'm telling you why
not do that by the way that's by the way
that's a different story I'm gonna tell
you what's so exciting for me please I
love what I think somebody is
disrespecting themselves I love when
somebody doesn't realize what they
actually have this has been the constant
communication that you and I've had in
the six staggered meetings over the last
four years I just genuinely believe in
you more than you believe in yourself
that might be the case that is the case
so what I'm I'm enjoying right now is
the following you're under estimating
what you pulled off the first time
Nichols you were you were and you
continued to be great
Lido's you can make a song up right now
I don't
I think you need to really give some
serious thought to something okay let me
give you example I didn't want to be
motivational stayed away from
motivational Gary for for three years an
arena I just don't want it but in the
last year I've been more okay with it
that I have historically because it
brings people value you may not want to
be the guy literally [ __ ] what every
single day can come up with a viral
[ __ ] song and video
I implore you to do it so that it gives
you so much [ __ ] leverage that you
can have your version of Beck when you
90 million people following you on three
platforms then you can do it you've
decided to leave the leverage on the
table and act like everybody else when
they don't have this skill and ability
you have to in 12 months be in a place
that's it forget about even monetizing
right to mobilize that mobilized the
[ __ ] are you at the mercy of that
because you've decided no no I'm doing
this now I'm doing two real news that I
have a proven thing
my formula I know what I can do yep I
know what I can meet L believe I just
some things never sell and that's fine
my man how do you think actual records
are gonna come out in three years listen
to me go and [ __ ] do this take your
[ __ ] Instagram be like hey guys
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
produce a [ __ ] music video and song
one minute long every day 365 days
starting tomorrow see you tomorrow and
then go make a [ __ ] flower in my
[ __ ] nose song and then go make a
[ __ ] I'm at [ __ ] Safeway and I eat
[ __ ] your oranges
every day one year and then do the right
house a Safeway yeah it's safe way out
here yeah California yeah safe way safe
wipe the [ __ ] is safe way if a bad guy
than the ask is you think you can do
everything I know I can do everything it
confuses people I don't give a [ __ ] do
you think people feel unintelligent when
they're confused ah I feel do you not
saying of course let me let me I Love
You Man no I feel very intelligent yes I
think most people feel unintelligent I
feel like there's a lot more things that
are gonna confuse them than Gary
Vaynerchuk and nicholas megalis i think
artists have the audacity to think that
they're the ones that are causing this
computer I don't think anybody's sitting
at home no it's funny till I'm at right
at home okay let me see everything going
on in society you know what a comedian I
don't have the audacity and you're
sitting here worried about 15 year old
Johnny in North Dakota saying you know
what I can't deal with what Nicholas is
putting out cool dude i opening right
it's not having that audacity it's a
blending humility with ego and I think
you're very close to that as close as
promote like dance that I've been
playing that I know and I love that
about you there's a fine line I love it
but visit reason I love John Lennon
there's a level of self-deprecation
required to be an artist - devil of
humility like
you know there's a reason that we don't
like certain things or they're above us
because they feel like they're above us
and I don't like that I'm a human being
but I would say my work that's funny and
genuine I'm queer so do a serious so do
it man yeah you're not making work right
now that a lot of people see true you
know the fire you had every morning in
the most prime of your career where
you're like holy [ __ ] it's coming no
matter good do you know why go figure
when you win when you get back to back
to going like [ __ ] I'm telling you I
know vision the difference between me
and everybody else in Hollywood do what
it is is I have ideas they literally
don't they're waiting for us to give
them ideas I mean that's how you make
your listen put it out
mmm and put yourself into a corner I'm
gonna make a video a mute one-minute
music video every [ __ ] one minute
megalis hashtag one minute megalis or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
and you will [ __ ] win people will be
like this you know what the first ones
gonna do you know if you actually listen
to me do it right now and tomorrow make
the first one what's gonna happen
everybody's gonna leave a comment like
this is what I [ __ ] love and they're
gonna tag the [ __ ] out of all their
friends who all came up with junior high
who are now seniors in high school and
being like I so many more somebody needs
to give you permission to do the magic
that you do don't let people judge and
don't you judge something that your
magical at sometimes don't you wish you
get shoes what your abilities are nope
what I wanted to get yes I do and let me
give you the answer you're looking for
know what I do instead is I go so deep
in those abilities take all the leverage
that come self in it and then take all
the leverage that comes with it so then
I can afford to do the stuff that I want
to do that is amazing advice I know and
I didn't even have to pay you for it
that's right incredible
I'm dead serious I know that's great
that's what I want you to do do what you
[ __ ] do better than anybody on earth
which is Nikolas you literally can make
the best music videos on Instagram in
the world you can do that you that's
insane
do a [ __ ] pissed I am that I can't do
that I would have 49 million followers
yeah I would mean bigger than everybody
you can do that and then when you have
that leverage guess who's calling
EDM guess who wants to give me record
deals all the people and you can do it
again
I did it cool do you know that was ahead
of I was listen how heartbreaking this
is for me
I was on YouTube four months after came
out I predicted it to me the biggest
thing I then left YouTube and went to
viddler there was a big mistake of mine
I've been rally gagged for years and had
when do you rock hit me up how long ago
do you rock now two years and two and a
half years ago I had 40,000 subscribers
on YouTube like it was like a non-factor
seven and a half years of being right
before the world and I'd 40,000 and and
and I wasn't embarrassed like all these
a list celebrities to go on networks I
was like I don't care what my number is
I know where it's gonna end up I don't
care where my number is I love where
it's gonna end up that's great you are
one of the great storytellers in the
format that we live in today yes I do
not see almost anybody else have the
ability to literally have the ability to
make 365 [ __ ] music but it's secure
does I know it is this in four months it
will be the thing everybody looks
forward to every single [ __ ] day in
four months and four months I'm gonna do
daily be [ __ ] 209 234 219 and I'm
gonna be like hey did you guys see what
happened to Nicolas today he's on
[ __ ] the Corden show for the [ __ ]
I eat sand paper on Thursdays okay okay
and I'm gonna be like let's recall me
telling him to do this saw in the
trailer that's good in my episode in
four months
that's how talented you are cool I'm
gonna try to not get into an accident
this is brilliant
are you promising me I wasn't you what
that you will tell mark like literally
make a video today that say you're gonna
do for three inches by phasing around
I'm just gonna do it no no I want the
promise I don't do it well then I'm
gonna do I'm telling you right now this
is our last meeting if you don't do it
yeah me on the smooth I'm gonna do what
I want you to make a music video for 365
days in a row let's talk let's stick
here I'm not really yes look at me look
at me real good I think this is you deal
with this every day
I feel literally like I'm in the
military this is like the trailer
understand no I'm serious too I believe
your life will be in an insanely amazing
place if you listen to me on this I know
they have to be extremely produced well
what did you used to do that's your
answer but that's the way things were
then man look at my face that's the way
things were look at my face ology wise
to listen to Mesa I am looking they're
the same right now we hit yes go into
[ __ ] Ralph all DIY all DUI I you have
talent dy I whatever I don't give a [ __ ]
50 rock shaky [ __ ] ha we're in the
zone here don't [ __ ] come on that's it
you ruined it I'm out no kidding I'm
gettin it you got this man
okay that's the real way I do listen to
me this is so big you know why I'm being
so I just want you here's something I'm
being selfish right now it is you cousin
9/11 want to say that it cracked you
yeah you that's how confident I am in
you know that's the ultimate compliment
and I believe me you're handing me that
it's ability I get it I feel like just
know you can do it man
feel it but let me ask you this yeah do
I deviate from that at all or is it
everyday just that no I think you
deviate from it I think you yep give me
some I'm so play no listen you're I'm
saying I know exactly I'm going your
Instagram right now you nailed it you
you can do both you're a network not a
show that's what I mean you're a
networks without a show is a network
you're a network not a show so so
so that's how I think also we have to
plug our [ __ ] shirts we want kids
exactly whatever it is that you we're
ready out of the shirts so all this [ __ ]
yeah you stay doing but every [ __ ]
for post if you're doing for a day
there's gonna be the music video okay
this is your the network and the music
video just happens to be one of it
probably gonna be the hit show it should
it be called nicholas megalis it should
it just be what should everything I do
be called megalis do you feeling I think
that's a semantics that that ends up not
mattering why because just as I'm
talking matter
we're not typing it in what do you mean
I don't want to make it as quickly as
[ __ ] that's possible for people to
access me it's that's a that's a yeah
that's a that's a semantics that doesn't
matter is this real short Airy I get it
but I have to [ __ ] silent ease at the
end of it so so listen me or see me I
feel you you will be you
dude this is this is what you do okay
like I'm telling you the same way that I
can you're looking at me like what like
I'm insane no no what I'm some what I'm
doing if you want to know what I'm doing
it I'm trying to put as much into you
because the second you walk out of that
trailer everything I put into you is
gonna start trickling the other way
you're right
I know know how the mind were I do
that's how meetings well so I'm trying
to make sure I ain't [ __ ] when I'm in it
when I'm in the room so that's why I'm
trying to get so much into you that by
the time you get out and by tomorrow
morning as long as you're still past the
Mendoza line to actually do it because
if I don't put this much you'll be here
and then you won't do it I'm telling you
right now you will [ __ ] explode in
[ __ ] a hundred days you're gonna make
one video that's gonna get ten million
views that's what you do okay
you wanted you want to do it I'll do
anything can't let do a video yeah would
you would you get in there and say that
we're gonna do it yeah I'll do anything
with you it on my Instagram yes we're
gonna say we're gonna do
Nicholas is gonna do I'm challenging
Nicholas say would you do that would you
say I'm challenge yes I think you start
and say something's happening and then
I'm gonna I'm gonna be the Puff Daddy to
your biggie yeah yeah I told them I told
them that was me that was me
[Laughter]
no it's mr. singsong name is Sean Combs
now wait so we gotta do it like this
this is a high on it I'm following your
lead I'm doing it like this I might I'm
gonna put my crop into it good I'm just
gonna say that every day I'm doing one
music video for the next year for the
next year 306 it's got six months no the
next year I'm gonna have a baby things
are gonna happen
to the [ __ ] baby you know what's
interesting you know what you know what
you want to know what's most interesting
about that moment what you're so good at
what you did and what you do I was able
to give it that stop Betsy that was
actually incredible moment I consumed no
content I know I'm not really I know
that's it the fact that you have
something like that I'm not gonna let
you [ __ ] waste it plug it on this
what the [ __ ] do you think this whole
episodes gonna be about how do we do it
I have no idea but I'm ready all right
hey guys nicholas megalis here with a
new challenge and introducing my friend
here you might recognize it's Gary Vee
listen I'm no Nicholas from the get you
know what he's amazing at I know what
he's amazing at and I told him it's time
to do what he does better than anybody
on earth so for the next 365 days this
man right here is going to be making a
song a day on Instagram
whose freaking the [ __ ] out I can't
curse on this channel you can curse [ __ ]
yeah
cool love you man
Wow I'm pumped up man dude I swear to
God on my life I'm telling you I'm gonna
say something wired this is where it
gets weird
pretty weird already I will never talk
to you again if there's not a video
tomorrow you will never talk to me ever
again I swear on my children Wow can I
can you say that I see it no you should
be this is for you and me listen me
that's gonna go in there listen listen
this no time I love you sit down a
second I really need this go ahead
this is very easy man brother I swear to
god you're the best [ __ ] music
storyteller on a mobile device in a
short-form format in the world I want
that to go on my tombstone fine please
do yourself a favor well you will you'll
get all the leverage I will live this
once before yeah we're just gonna do it
again you'll get all the leverage you
should give the people what they want
one year of you getting all the leverage
and that will buy you the permission to
do whatever you want you'll know how to
handle it better differently cool you'll
know what to do I'm actually excited to
leave so I can do it super fun I want
what that's I want that don't do it
that's I'm serious though I believe you
I'm not I'm taking everything very
seriously what you're saying I know you
are I know you know me there's a reason
I'm here man like I believe in you and I
know you believe in me I do brother I'll
talk to you Shelby deserves it I'll talk
to you tomorrow
peace peace out peace
hi everybody is this recording I'm
nicholas megalis and this tiny woman is
lady Ophelia megalis
I'm here to tell you briefly about song
of the day when I came to Gary he
basically forced me almost at gunpoint
to do song of the day and it bettered me
in ways that I don't even I can't even
express in words it forced me into a
routine of creating every single day
getting up not even thinking just making
making making and pretty soon you get
your confidence back
you get your fire back you're creating
for a purpose it's now part of a plan
organizing myself creatively and and
having that rigid routine push me in the
direction of making a record man and it
opened doors for me and got me in front
of more people and now because of
meeting with Gary we are go fund me we
are crowdsourcing our record we're
making an album a real album we're doing
it donate if you can if you can't just
share it I love you Gary you are a
brother to me thank you so [ __ ] much
you